for seven years bahrain camp
and others like it have become home for
those who fled isil's assault
and takeover of large parts of iraq in
2014.
now the iraqi government wants the
people to go home and these camps are
under threat of closure
but those here say they have nowhere to
go
i can't go back because here we have
some help at least
our house is destroyed there's nothing
to return back to
if we go back where do we live under the
sky here at least we have a tent
the government wants us out of this camp
but they haven't helped us to go
anywhere else
since being set up seven years ago has
become home
to many babies have become children
families have forged bonds with each
other
the camp provides basic services such as
water and limited electricity
but still offers more of a community
than the destroyed houses they left
behind
the iraqi government has shut 16 of 20
camps it controls down
and is putting pressure on the
autonomous kurdish regional government
to shut camps in its territory the camp
director works for an ngo linked to the
kurdish regional government
which together with the iraqi federal
government finances the camps
the kurdish regional government won't
cut the aid to these families and we
won't force them to return back
if they want to leave we'll help them
leave the federal government has stopped
some aid in a bid to encourage people to
leave
every month more families arrive at this
camp from others that have been closed
the iraqi federal government has stopped
helping new rivals with food parcels
and the camp's managers can only give
them shelter they also say
they have nothing at home to return to
and this is what they don't want to
return back to now when isil took over
mosul in 2014
they killed or displaced most of the
population
then when the iraqi forces took it back
whole neighborhoods like these
were completely destroyed but it's not
just here
it's also in villages and towns
surrounding mosul where a lot of these
displaced people come from
now here the pace of rebuilding is slow
but in those smaller towns and villages
it's practically non-existent most of
the rebuilding effort seems to be
focused on the unesco heritage site
the al-nuri mosque the former
headquarters of isil
but with few homes even remotely livable
who might go to the rebuilt mosque
is under question if families move back
without homes and jobs
it will make the situation worse they
will beg in the streets
and this will worsen the already bad
economic situation
most of these families are eligible for
compensation
but few families have received anything
out of the 73 000 families who have
asked for help to rebuild
and move home since 2018 only 2 000
have received help according to human
rights groups
for thousands of people the camps are
their only option but
there are a few left and the pressure to
shut them is growing every day
imran khan al jazeera mosul